le tir c'est pour gagner aujourd'hui il
fallait jouer le 4 le 19 et le 3 la
météo toujours de la pluie mais les
dégâts du froid ne sont pas encore
oublié l'enquète d'alain doublé ce qui
en normandie
les anglais commencent à exploiter leur
pétrole ils ont déjà la plus grande
plateforme du monde en écosse invité du
journal
les mariés de pékin elle est française
il est chinois pour la première fois en
direct à la télévision
bonsoir dimanche mouillé mouillé pour
tout le monde ou presque un dimanche
marquée surtout par la douceur du temps
la pluie est venue de l'ouest et a
traversé doucement la france pour
terminer ce soir sur l'alsace la
lorraine et le nord entre temps le
soleil a joué à cache cache avec les
nuages un hiver donc qui a déjà un
avant-goût de printemps
les pluies les plus abondantes sont
tombées sur le midi à montaut et à nice
en particulier il ya eu des éboulements
et plusieurs glissements de terrain pour
demain vous le voyez sur cette carte
bis repetita temps doux et passagèrement
pluvieux pluies plus abondantes sur le
sud du pays avec quelques orages et de
la neige en montagne au dessus de 15 100
m et puis de la plus également sur la
manche
ailleurs il y aura des éclaircies ce
redoux général ne doit pas nous faire
oublier que des milliers de foyers sont
encore privés d'électricité
conséquence des chutes de neige et des
gelées de la semaine dernière qui avait
touché la normandie en particulier vous
souvenez bien sûr de ce blizzard de
cette tempête de neige de cette pluie
bizarre qui se transformer en glace en
touchant le sol
en quelques heures la normandie avait
pris des airs de sibérie lignes
électriques câbles de téléphone coupées
les milliers de poteaux brisé à la
nouvelle ce qui est retourné voir en
normandie comment cette région sorte est
maintenant de son hibernation
tout le monde a mis la main à la pâte
pour aider les sinistrés de normandie
équipement pause et chaussées pompiers
edf l'armée également est intervenu
pendant quelques jours priorité l'eau
potable les stations de pompage
fonctionne à l'électricité dès à présent
toutes les communes sont alimentés en
eau grâce à des groupes électrogènes
venus du nord et de la région parisienne
la circulation rétablie sur toutes les
routes des quantités énormes d'arbres
s'était abattue sur les chaussées ainsi
que sur les voies de chemin de fer
la remise en état des lignes électriques
moyenne et basse tension se poursuit
difficilement à travers des terrains
inondés qu'il faut traverser à pied car
les camions s'enlise les agents edf
venus d'autres départements prêtent main
forte à leurs collègues de l'heure
d'après les premières estimations il
faudra encore une dizaine de jours avant
que toutes les communes retrouve
téléphone et électricité
en ce qui concerne l'activité économique
ce sont surtout les entreprises de la
région de bernay qui ont été touchés une
boulangerie industrielle a été dépannée
la première elle fournit le pain à plus
de 5000 personnes
les premiers jours c'était l'affolement
la panique à seulement lundi et mardi
affolement appelant tous les domaines la
course au parcours sont bougies la cour
son gaz la course un peu tout alors par
la suite vous avez été
par la chute lundi dépannage iron
offrait une boulangerie industrielle et
lundi soir groupe électrogène fournies
par les autorités
ce boulanger bien sûr pas c'est avant
tout des autres
ils ont fait preuve d'imagination ou
bien ils ont appelé ce parisien
débrouillards qui les a rapidement
dépanné dès lundi matin
ils louaient des groupes électrogènes et
un camion les agriculteurs aussi ont été
sinistrées plus particulièrement ceux
dont l'exploitation est électrifié c'est
le cas de cet éleveur de bovins qui
produit 900 litres de lait par jour
provisoirement tout fonctionne je viens
juste d'être secourue par un particulier
qui a pris l'initiative d'aller louer
des groupes à paris et nous les mettre à
notre disposition la sous préfecture
nous et après vous promis non ils m'ont
dit qu'il n'y avait rien de prévu pour
nous dépanner qu'ils avaient des
priorités à respecter
j'ai pourtant demandé que une fois que
les premières priorités était satisfaite
que ce qu'on veut placer quand même dans
un certain ordre décroissant pour
obtenir un dépannage vous pensez vous
serez indemnisé non par qui voulez vous
qu'on soit indemnisé le plan orsec n'a
pas été décrété
il a été mis en place un plan m'ignore
sexe ou perdu 10 d'expression pour faire
face à la situation
pourquoi la région n'a pas été déclarée
zone sinistrée pour l'instant c'est ce
problème est à l'étude au niveau de
monsieur le préfet arrive on ne sait pas
encore si les entrepreneurs les
exécuteurs seront indemnisés 20 je ne
peux pas vous répondre sur ce point
jusqu'à peu pour l'instant le montant
des dégâts de fpt tête impossible à
chiffrer il sera d'autant plus élevé que
le matériel installé et provisoire
les poteaux de bois plus légers
permettront d'attendre que le sol soit
moins d tropez et que les engins de
travaux publics plus d'installer les
pylônes définitif en grande partie à
cause de la douceur du temps ce week-end
la ruée vers la neige des parisiens pour
les vacances de février s'est passée
sans embouteillage quelques petits
bouchons après lyon du côté de chambéry
mais ces bouchons ont sauté en quelques
heures bison futé est optimiste pour ce
soir malgré les derniers départs de la
zone c et les retours de la zone b les
soucis commenceront dimanche prochain
pense bison futé le président giscard
d'estaing et son épouse prennent
quelques jours de repos au fort de
brégançon après avoir assisté à une
messe à fréjus ce matin le chef de
l'état a visité un camp d' art qui près
de bormes les mimosas discussions avec
les habitants du camp et dégustation de
merguez dans l'actualité de ce dimanche
également l'augmentation des allocations
de chômage à compter du 20 février les
taux journaliers de location pendant les
trois premiers mois passent à 16 francs
50 contre 13 francs 50 précédemment et
la majoration pour conjoint et personne
à charge passe à 6 francs 60 contre cinq
francs 40 précédemment la politique
maintenant débuts demain lundi à la
télévision et à la radio de la campagne
électorale officielle
le tirage au sort hier a indiqué que le
premier mouvement intervenir sera la
démocratie chrétienne donna soir et le
dernier ce sera le rpr le vendredi 10
mars au soir
et bien évidemment il y a eu bon nombre
de réunions de discours et de petites
phrases pendant ce week-end françois
mitterrand par exemple était ce matin
dans le 12e arrondissement de paris pour
soutenir deux candidats socialistes
madame touré une mesure phare en jce pas
d'incident pas tomates lancé par des
militants d'extrême droite comme la
semaine dernière mais au contraire une
atmosphère bon enfant sur le marché de
la place d'aligre en particulier
conversation avec les commerçants
poignées de main et petit jeu de
questions réponses avec les habitants du
quartier
hier soir à lille françois mitterrand a
lancé un appel à l'union sur la base du
programme commun nous ne refuserons dû
disputer aucune opposition lorsque le
moment sera venu at il dit l'une des
petites phrases de ce week-end mais il y
en a eu bien d'autres
bernard pradines ce matin à privas par
exemple monsieur georges marchais a
repris ses griefs contre le parti
socialiste le ps nous demande de nous
désister en sa faveur mais il faut
d'abord dire de quelle façon nous
gouvernerons grâce au vote du 12 mars
les électeurs tiennent entre leurs mains
la quête du succès hier soir à granville
monsieur de faire on était resté à la
stratégie électorale en expliquant
qu'une rencontre entre partis de gauche
devraient avoir lieu logiquement après
le premier tour pour un appel au
désistement pour la majorité c'est dans
l'express que le premier ministre
affirme que le climat social serait
tendu en cas de victoire de la gauche et
que toujours dans cette hypothèse ce
serait les pauvres qu'ils paieraient le
plus à cause de la fiscalité et de la
hausse des prix dans une interview
accordée au quotidien italien la stampa
monsieur jacques chirac précise qu'en
cas de victoire de la majorité actuelle
le soutien du rpr au nouveau
gouvernement dépendra de l'action
politique proposé par ce gouvernement
l'invité du club de la presse d'europe 1
était ce soir monsieur mendès-france
pour lui le chaos est à craindre si la
majorité actuelle l'emport et cette
situation pourrait conduire à de très
graves aventure à la question
accepteriez vous d'être ministre d'un
gouvernement de gauche
monsieur mendès-france a répondu que
tout dépendrait de l'autorité de qui
aura la charge de choisir les ministres
et aussi du programme qu'ils voudraient
appliquer j - 14 donc pour le premier
tour des élections législatives en
france évidemment la campagne électorale
tient une grande très large place dans
l'actualité
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à
l'étranger aussi on suit de très près ce
débat électoral et en particulier chez
nos voisins européens
nous aurons l'occasion dans les jours
qui viennent de vous montrer comment
anglais et allemands par exemple observe
de l'autre côté de la manche du rhin la
préparation des élections législatives
françaises
ce soir intéressons nous aux italiens
victor amant notre correspondant
permanent à rome s'est adressé pour ce
faire aux journalistes du quotidien
repubblica
la repubblica
c'est un quotidien qui a été lancé il ya
deux ans le succès a été immédiat
présentation moderne et beaucoup
d'informations la moitié des lecteurs de
la repubblica en moins de 25 ans la
repubblica accorde une place importante
à la situation politique en france c'est
vrai d'ailleurs pour tous les journaux
italiens
mais pour quelle raison cette fois ci il
est vraiment un grand d'intérêt italiens
de l'opinion publique inverse la
situation politique française parce que
il y avait là un élément qui fascine et
eu une grande partie de l'opinion
publique italienne samedi il y avait le
projet de l'union de la gauche
je crois que la chose le plus
intéressant sera de voir ce qui se
passera après les élections la phrase si
vous aurez un gouvernement de gauche
communistes socialistes qui apparaît
difficile à ces moments ne sont vraiment
ça oui
une réfl échir médias sur la position
des communistes italiens
si au contraire on aura un accord entre
giscard et mitterrand et disons les
gaullistes tendance du côté les
communistes et l'autre selon dehors eh
bien ça pourrait aider
il accorde un socialiste de mons retient
et nathalie saha je trouve une espèce d
parallèle un peu compliqué tout ça
c'était compliqué mais c'est compliqué
les italiens sont tellement habitués aux
marchandages qui ont compromis dans leur
vie politique qu'il trouverait tout à
fait normal que le président giscard
d'estaing arrivent à s'entendre un jour
avec françois mitterrand
en revanche ils sont quelque peu
désorientés par la rudesse le côté
systématique des moeurs politiques
françaises une gauche en général en
italie qui parle d'une façon très
nuancée parce que la gauche est prête au
dialogue avec les autres forces
politiques parce que la gauche pense
toujours qu'il faudra gouverner avec les
modérés passé mis une grande majorité
plutôt qu'une majorité à 50 1 52% et et
voilà ça a créé ce langage
exclamant nuancé langage qui n'est pas
tellement significatif en france vous
avez je sais pas si c'est c'est une
c'est un élément positif ou négatif mais
quand même vous avez un à gages
politique très près seulement parce que
la gauche appelle les autres la joie les
autres appellent la gauche la gauche
enfin quand il ya des élections en
italie il ne s'agit pas de changer de
société la vie politique y est confuse
mouvante incertaine comme la circulation
dans les rues de rome
il ya même plus d'opposition en italie
on comprend alors cette fascination que
provoquent les événements en france on
trouve chez le voisin une passion et une
âpreté dont on a perdu le goût et la
saveur mais dont on a gardé peut-être
une certaine nostalgie aux philippines
enlèvement d'un haut fonctionnaire
français par trois rebelles musulmans
pierre huguet 59 ans fonctionnaire au
ministère des finances était en vacances
dans le sud des philippines lorsque
trois hommes armés de fusils ont obligé
à monter dans un bateau avant de
s'enfuir vers la haute mer il ya eu une
fusillade d'ailleurs entre les rebelles
et les policiers philippins pour
l'instant pas de trace de monsieur guay
ni de ses ravisseurs en chine 8 contre
révolutionnaires ont été exécutés on
leur reprochait de faire de la
propagande pour saper le système
socialiste
l'information qui nous est parvenu
beaucoup plus rapidement que de coutume
mais c'est sans doute un signe de cette
ouverture de la chine dont on parle de
plus en plus et en particulier depuis le
retour au premier plan de monsieur thank
you ping et de la confirmation du
pouvoir du nouveau numéro un chinois
monsieur voit cours offerts à pékin
aujourd'hui le successeur de mauro cetto
président est devant près de 3500 député
l'ouverture de la 5e assemblée nationale
populaire chinoise n'a semblé qui en
raison de la mort de mao et du limogeage
de la bande des quatre s'est tenue trois
ans avant sa date normale des députés
qui représentent les 900 millions de
chinois
ont adoptés vont adopter une nouvelle
constitution de l'état et nommé un
nouveau gouvernement ce matin dans la
presse de pékin on parlait de la
nouvelle longue marche
dirigée par monsieur roy pour ping pour
une chine redéfinit comme une démocratie
socialiste puissante et moderne avec
nous donc ce soir dans le journal
d'antenne de les marier de pékin c'est à
dire odile pierquin et son mari tianli
vous savez depuis deux ans on suit on a
suivi votre idylle un petit peu avec
indiscrétions d'ailleurs et vos démêlés
en particulier avec l'administration
chinoise et tout le monde s'est réjoui
si de votre mariage finalement le
premier mariage d'ailleurs en train
chinois est une étrangère depuis la fin
de la révolution culturelle est ce que
vous pensez que votre mariage aurait été
possible à l'époque demande c'est ou
encore
national ligne bakchich chez sigma
dossier potuznik
oui on pense que quand on aurait pu et
se marier et finir en france pour moi
pour un certain temps dans la mesure où
les dirigeants actuels continuent la
ligne définie par le président mais pour
nous il n'ya pas il n'y a pas eu de
changement vraiment décoller mais au
dessus de la bière sinon je pense tout
cas de changement radical au moins pour
ceux sur cette question dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment de libéralisation
l'a vu avec les réunions de cette
assemblée populaire
alors est ce que cette libéralisation
est sensible au niveau quotidien pour
les gens pour ceux qui travaillent pour
ce qu' ils sont dans les usines par
exemple des comptes gmail cannes du
choix des médias nous sommes au
royaume-uni tard deviendra ce gène dans
guitar hero
you may you can't say you say me crois
que je suis un bon tiers des jeunes
jouent bien leur rôle incombe aux gens
pour qu'ils soient terminés pour yo yo
mais j'ai bien géré le single you can't
be au niveau politique oui il ya eu
certains changements au niveau de la
théologie et autrefois par exemple
beaucoup de mots creux et alors que
maintenant on leur demande d'être
utiliser plus d'énergie au service de la
nation qui peuplent dans la vie de tous
les jours [ __ ] ça que je me permets
qu'on a une liberté de parole un peu
plus grande une liberté de réunion un
peu plus grand danger leur fait voyager
pariant d'antenne soit chaud à cette
idée y tient comme bordeaux triaud le
cas quelques agents de réunion
lorsque les gens veulent de parler
politique par exemple j'ai changé d idée
voici un foyer des femmes aux critiques
avaient fusé pays tient tout forme une
picoseconde il dit pour dire ce qu'on
pense
en politique
oui pense qu'il ya plus de liberté
qu'avant on parle souvent de la bande
des quatre est ce que la bande des
quatre dont la femme de mao tsé tout
faisait partie bien entendu est ce que
cette bande des quatre était importante
pour les chinois est ce que ça a eu des
répercussions sur la vie quotidienne en
chine
sagen 24 heures minimum etienne de
chambre au yom et hôpitaux tard des
initiants citent lâcher
quant à cindy lauper john ging
nomination bien sûr il y avait une
influence est grande et 4 et en
particulier sur la vie économique le
niveau économique de la chine
ils ont pourquoi ils ont pas mal des
trades et enfin empêcher l'évolution de
la vie économique et un développement
économique normale et vous dit vous avez
senti ou un changement le changement que
j'ai ressentie au niveau de moi je veux
pas juger le changement qu'il ya dans
les usines puisque j'étais pas ouvrir
mais la manière dont les gens
réagissaient par rapport à la critique
t4 j'ai bien vu que will hahn mettait
enfin il l'année paye là c'était quelque
chose de très bien qu on al impression
lorsqu'on est à pékin laisse conduire
lorsqu'on voyage en chine que les
chinois sont très disciplinés très
organisé certains disent attention
goulag
alors est ce que vous vous avez souffert
de ce genre de pression sur les gens pas
d'un minimum de ti l'ue cherche une
parade aux de till lindemann benjamines
fjord activity le coucher très tard
la suite et anti moubarak
non cette cette discipline elle répond
souvent à des besoins ressentis par la
population
recueilli par exemple récemment il ya
une campagne sur la discipline dans la
circulation avec un pass était
nécessaire parce qu'il y avait vraiment
pas mal de désordre si ça permet d'avoir
moins d'accidents au moins deux
incidents bicyclette quand c'est pas des
désaxés en bicyclette et de camions ça
c'est moi qu'elle joue ici c'est mieux
c'est mieux mais si les 6,6 à moins de
gens qui vont à l'hôpital à cause de la
circulation
vous allez retourner en chine on
reconnaît bien sûr on combien de temps
ni grain sinon vous pouvez créer un
corps de chien
ça dépendra mais certainement restera
pas très longtemps en france je pense
que c'est le temps de ses études puisque
on est venu pour ça que je dois d'avoir
un bébé ça prendra moins de temps que de
faire les deux
merci beaucoup et meilleur la part du
journal d'antenne 2 à pékin vous le
savez on suit de très près le conflit
qui oppose depuis plusieurs semaines
déjà le cambodge et le vietnam
ce matin encore la radio de phnom penh a
demandé aux soldats révolutionnaires et
aux paysans cambodgiens de lutter pour
défaire les agresseurs vietnamien et le
sources vietnamiennes en revanche on a
appris que les cambodgiens avaient lancé
une offensive est franchi la frontière
voici d'ailleurs sur une carte où se
déroule en ce moment les combats tayninh
est la dernière ville vietnamienne avant
la frontière cambodgienne ici au centre
de la carte
c'est donc dans cette région que
cambodgien et vietnamiens s'affrontent
et vietnam y affirme que trois ou quatre
divisions khmers rouges ont franchi
leurs frontières
trois ou quatre divisions cambodgienne
le chip semble un peu fort dans la
mesure où ce serait donc presque la
moitié de toute l'armée cambodgienne qui
se trouvera engagés dans ce secteur
limité et puis l'armée cambodgienne
compte 90 mille hommes l'armée
vietnamienne plus de 700 mille autres
éléments de réflexion qui fait donc
douter d'une offensive générale
cambodgienne en territoire vietnam ces
images en noir et blanc qui nous ont été
envoyées par une oreille et nam
approuve que dans cette région les
combats sont semblant est dur c'est la
seule certitude que nous ayons pour le
reste aucun journée s'est rangé n'a pu
vérifier les informations nord vietnam
c'est peut-être pour briser ce
scepticisme général que monsieur funding
qui est en visite officielle en inde en
ce moment a donné une conférence de
presse n'est pas coutumier du fait c'est
donc un événement
et il affirmé que son pays était prêt à
négocier dans les plus brefs délais et
que les mythes amiens n'était pas à
l'origine de ces incidents et
cambodgiens quant à eux prétendent le
contraire et n'accepteront de négocier
qu'à partir du moment où les troupes de
hanoï auront quitté l'île le territoire
cambodgien
je rappelle que l'un des hommes qui
avaient longtemps vrai pour ramener la
paix au sud est asiatique jean sainteny
ancien ministre du général de gaulle
ancien haut-commissaire de la france en
indochine
jean sainteny est mort hier à paris à
l'âge de 71 ans je vous parle de
référendum en suisse
hier soir de nos traditions de 20 heures
à propos de la réduction des horaires de
travail un reportage de denise robert
il a ce soir un résultat résultat d'un
référendum concernant l'âge de la
retraite c'est un résultat tout aussi
étonnant d'ailleurs que le reportage de
denise boisvert hier soir les suisses
ont refusé massivement que l'âge de la
retraite soit abaissé de 65 à 60 ans
pour les hommes et de 62 à 58 ans pour
les femmes je n'ai pas encore
d'explications sur ce refus la tour
montparnasse
vous connaissez évidemment il a imaginé
la tour montparnasse qui flotte sur la
mer au large de l'ecosse c'est l'exploit
que viennent de réaliser les
constructeurs de la plus grande
plateforme pétrolière du monde à kirsch
horn en écosse un exploit franco
britannique
le monstre mesure 230 mètres de haut et
pèse 600 mille tonnes un monstre à la
mesure des vieilles légendes écossaise
dans ce pays on n'attendait plus rien
pourtant l'apparition n'a guère surpris
parce qu'ici seuls les fous ne croient
plus aux mystères de la mer et du vent
une vieille légende disait qu'un jour un
monstre surgir et des eaux de la baie
d'apple cross et qui ne ressemblerait à
aucune créature connue sur nos rivages a
aucune bête de la montagne alors bien
sûr quand on a construit la plateforme
tout le monde s'est souvenu du monstre
de la légende
les gens du west europe n'ont pas peur
du monstre d'aujourd'hui il ne crache
que des statistiques
quatre cent mille tonnes de béton 23
mille tonnes d'acier et 229 m de la tête
à la queue c'est la plus grande
plateforme pétrolière du monde
elle coûtera 200 milliards de centimes
alors pour mettre le ciel de leur côté
les écossais l'ont baptisé ni nian du
nom du saint patron protecteur de leur
pays
demain ni nian sera une ville usine de
5000 m² au pourront vivre jour et nuit
les 200 personnes chargés de pomper le
pétrole enfoui sous la mer ici ce que
toi et que ces anglais américains
irlandais ou français sur cette tour de
babel flottante tous les corps de
métiers sont là
bon je m'appelle jean dida j'habite
paris je suis ici depuis six mois où je
m'occupe principalement de mesures
météorologiques de résistance de
matériaux et aussi de stabilité mauvaise
daniel vois je suis à qui chante depuis
un an et demi environ
j'habite paris ici je m'occupe de
l'installation des câbles électriques
l'appel nicole jean-marie jeu puis de
lens je suis là depuis dix mois et je
croyais la mise en action pour divers
matériels pour gagner un peu plus qu'aux
pays
ces hommes travaille 12 heures par jour
et cela trois semaines par mois quand le
vent souffle à 120 kilomètres/heure le
moindre faux pas peut être fatal
il y a eu deux accidents mortels le
risque c'est notre boulot affirme la
chanson des hommes de la plateforme
ban
m
voici jean françois coux pau 27 ans mais
déjà une lourde responsabilité
depuis trois ans il va ya la stabilité
de l'édifice
un travail de funambule car à chaque
étape de la construction
la moindre erreur de calcul peut rompre
l'équilibré de l'ensemble parce que la
plateforme flotte à la manière d'une
bouteille dont on a laissé le fond grâce
à ce système de ballast
on peut stocker 400 mille tonnes d'eau
de mer dans les entrailles du monstre
110 mètres en dessous du niveau de la
mer
tout ce que vous voyez ici est amené à
disparaître parce que cette pièce qui
fait 5000 mètres cubes en gros le
servira de réserve de pétrole non pas le
pétrole pompé par la plateforme mais le
pétrole qui sert à faire fonctionner
toutes les installations de la
plateforme une fois posé les dernières
poutrelles installer la plateforme pour
hélicoptères ni nian pèsera 1 million de
tonnes l'équivalent de 50 porte avions
restera encore à gagner un second pari
son remorquage sans histoire sur 700 km
vers les gisements de la mer du nord
dans quelques mois ce sera le grand
départ on y songe déjà avec une pointe
de regret jean françois michel et les
autres se sont attachés au pays autant
qu'à leur travail savoir si je suis plus
attaché à la plateforme ou à l'ecosse
ont ma femme vous dirais que je suis
plus attaché à la plate forme mais je
pense que j'aime beaucoup les causses et
si nous avons un autre contrat ici c'est
avec grand plaisir que je resterai pour
une seconde plate forme mais je pense
quand vous êtes très attaché à l'école
ceci qu est ce que vous y faites tel en
dehors de votre travail
on doit à mon travail bien quand j'ai
quelques temps libre on va à la chasse
et à la pêche pour la partir de pâques
comme la différence que promet le
paysage
aujourd'hui grâce aux 400 emplois locaux
créés par la plateforme agriculture et
tourisme ne sont plus les seuls 7 ou de
la région il n'est pas sûr toutefois que
l'on décide de construire une seconde
plateforme
tout dépendra des résultats grâce au
pétrole de la mer du nord le royaume uni
entend couvrir ses besoins dès 1980 et
dès la fin de cette année nine yann
devrait produire à elle seule 10 mille
tonnes de brut par jour
l'affairé empain de nouveau des rumeurs
à propos de la rançon elles auraient été
versés en totalité ou en partie aux
ravisseurs en suisse officiellement
évidemment aucune confirmation tant du
côté de la famille que du côté de la
police le silence qui entoure cette
affaire a simplement été brisés par les
banquiers suisses qui ont expliqué hier
qu'un versement pourrait éventuellement
être fait dans leur établissement
à condition qu'on le leur demande il
accepte il accepterait alors pour des
raisons humanitaires
il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui dans la
4e course à auteuil le prix de la croix
dauphine dans ce tiercé pour gagner ce
tiercé il fallait jouer le 4 le 19 et le
3 le 4 c
marware suivi de la wii vous le 19 et 2
n'aurait dit le trois reprises se
profiler dans la ligne droite la
dernière ligne droite
la fameuse dernière ligne droite 4 19 3
une combinaison gagnante qui vous
rapporte pour 5 francs dans l'ordre 45
1991 francs 50 pour 5 francs donc et
dans un ordre différent 7602 francs 50
pour 504 19 et 3 voilà ils sont arrivés
vous retrouverez hervé clos pour la
dernière édition du journal vers 23h ce
soir je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée sur antenne 2
à